This is like an ISIS beheading video. This is like a This is
literally like Banana is in the room staring her down right now.
>> Not frivolous.
>> Does Do we not Do we not understand what the implications?
>> Holy [__] >> This is amazing. This
is so [laughter]
>> Dude, I love it. I love it. This is like an ISIS beheading
video and I love that. I love compelled speech. I love compelled
speech. Compelled speech. That's my favorite thing. Let's go,
bro. I'm now I'm excited now. Now that Pisco's video has ended.
Okay, now I think his stream's ended. Now that his stream has
ended, okay, now I want to go to the end and actually watch his
reaction to Caseyron video cuz oh my goodness, his actual reaction
to Casey Tron video should be so good. It could be so good,
>> right? Let's go. Let's go. Let's check it out. end by
stating I take responsibility for infringing the content nuke.
I want to begin by stating I take responsibility for infringing
the content nuke. The lawsuit was not frivolous. When I said
the lawsuit was frivolous and based on misogyny, it was to garner
sympathy, protect my own reputation, and retaliate against the
clients.
This
what part of any Casey has like the longest history of anybody
on the internet? Okay. There is the most examples of her conduct
of her the way she thinks. What part of this statement is consistent
with how she's acted for the past decade and a half. Literally
zero of it. Like she doesn't think this at all. Obviously, >> this
lawsuit has given me a greater understanding of copyright protection,
people's copyrights, and the importance of protecting copyrights
in the online content creation community. >> Dude, are
you serious? This is such dude. I I also hold on before before
he reacts. I also want to know just a little bit. Okay.
If
he demanded this go up front. I do. I really want to know if
he actually if someone if his lawyers or he dictated the order
and was like actually the first thing you need to say is that
this was about copyright cuz I need people to know that the most
important thing is about copyright protections.
Would it set a legal precedent for everybody though? It's civil.
civil court. The civil courts are different than the uh criminal
courts. And yes, you can set civil precedents obviously.
>> Yes, absolutely. >> I'm sorry. >> Or sorry,
they might even be they might even be the the would they be the
same courts? I don't know. It's a different system. It's like
they're they're handled differently. There's different rules.
This pretense
this is really about pretend. >> I don't I don't know if
they're literally different courts. You might be able to do both
like judge criminal and civil cases. I I doubt they're actually
different courts, but they are different like tracks of the court.
>> Different rules. >> Oh my god. Give me a break.
And it's never ending. It's This is so so
>> that this is what they choose to start
>> Oh my god. >> Your newfound appreciation for the
copyright statute. Uh just so absurd.
>> No, hold on. I think that's probably true. I think that's
actually probably true. Oh my god. I've been for a Caseyron.
She full reacts to like movies and on Twitch, right? To fully
like TV channels and [laughter] it's got to be the case. No,
this actually did create a new understanding for her. Uh I could
be financially for doing the thing I do every day.
community to respectual
property rights of other creators and I will adhere to the lessons
I've learned throughout this process going forward. >> I
also want to make clear that I did not receive any support financial
or otherwise from Hassan Pike. >> Oh boy. >> Hassan
never even reached out to me privately to offer words of support.
Speaking honestly, I found his indifference to my suffering hurtful,
especially after he hinted he might help me behind the scenes.
Dude, how [__] up is it that Ethan Klein gets to
get Casey Tron to do anything? Okay,
>> dude. You know, you know there would be uh you can make
her do anything and he's like, "Say Assan is bad. Assan is bad.
Say Assan is bad. Assan is bad." Say it. Say it. Say it. >> Say
it. [laughter] It felt like he wanted to receive credit from
the public from helping me without providing any.
>> As to the GoFundMe money, to the extent there are any
remaining funds after I pay my attorney's fees, I have agreed
to pay the remaining funds to the clients. >> The funds
will not go any to anyone else, including Denims or Frogan to
defend their lawsuits.
>> For the record, I have agreed to cooperate with the
client.
>> This is what we said earlier. And then actually Hassan
said the same thing. Didn't even realize it. Hassan said the
same thing.
And then Ethan reacted to Hassan saying the same thing. And Ethan's
like, "Why are you blaming this on Israel? How how am I like
Israel?
Does Israel like blackmail people into making statements?" Wait,
are you saying you blackmailed her to making this statement?
Hold on. What? Excuse me.
Wait, what did you just admit to? Hello. >> In their litigation
against the H3 Snark mods for promoting my live stream to the
extent that I am able. I will offer my support, including testifying
under oath [laughter] to everything I have just stated to help
their cause. >> I also want to take the opportunity to
acknowledge other misconduct and bad behavior I have exhibited.
>> Well, I can't do it. Dude, I have to run this stream.
Okay, if you're going to redeem it like a thousand times in a
row, I cannot do it every time. Asan is bad. As bad as it's bad
is bad. It's bad. Asan is bad. Asan is bad. As it's bad. Okay,
there you go. >> Online cool down. exampleizing the death
the death of Asmin Gold's mother was
>> I [snorts] should know better because I have three disabled
people that rely on me. Moving forward, I will do better. I also
want to apologize to the crew of the H3.
I the person who would write this actually gets off to like total
by the way like like you actually like the idea not that you
would somebody but you like like the idea of a woman being woman
being violated while held at knife point like that is the fetish
of the person who dictated this these terms who dictated this
transcript. Okay, let's just be real. You are 100% into that.
Okay. It's not even close to a question >> particularly
a >> that you could like watch this thing that you coerced
her into doing obviously. So, all right. And watch along with
it and go, "Oh, that was really good." Yeah, you like that, don't
you? Yeah. Casey, you like that, don't you, Casey? Casey, don't
you like that dick? You like that dick, Casey? Sorry. I'm saying
as the person who made it, who who got her to do this, and you
watch along, you go, "Yeah, you like that dick, don't you, Casey?
Don't you? Don't you, Casey? You love that. You love it. Don't
you?" I apologize for calling them cowards for not quitting their
jobs. That was a shameful attack on two people who deeply care
about Palestine and Palestinian. >> Hey, I'm just telling
you what is going on in Ethan Klein's mind. I'm sorry that Ethan
Klein's mind is a deviant and disgusting place. Okay, but that's
absolutely what was going on in his head while she was saying
these things.
Like he's he has her totally in his power. He's compelling these
statements from her, right? Completely.
She's clearly in discomfort. She's clearly not not feeling it
at all. And the more uncomfortable she is, the more turned on
he is. It's very disgusting stuff. Okay. >> People AB along
with his wife Lena have done more than I have ever done for the
Palestinian people, including raising over $100,000 in charity.
I recognize that they have actually made Palestinian lives better,
and my online antagonism and trolling has not.
>> Just wait the next one. If the next one doesn't send
Pisco totally, I don't know what I'm watching even. Okay. [laughter]
Actually, I can't believe that I said AB doesn't love Palestine.
AB and his wife have raised so much money for Palestine. That
was really [__] up of me to say. >> I apologize
to Ethan and Hila personally. I have said extremely mean and
cruel things about both of them, particularly my misogynistic
attacks against Hila that never should have been said. I also
want to acknowledge the pervasive problem of anti-semitism in
leftist spaces. It should concern all of us. I condemn it and
will not participate in it. To that end, I wish the client's
success in enforcing Ted Entertainment's copyright. >> Dude,
I
the wheels have to be turning in his head, right? He's got to
be so close to losing it right here. He's got to be right there.
>> And protecting the legal rights of online content creators.
uh instant reaction leaves a horrible taste in my mouth. It it
it just lays bare that they're they're using the copyright statute
to settle scores on unrelated matters. The whole pretense this
is about um protecting property is so at this point it's offensive.
Um and yeah um he in in any other context we would criticize
this kind of uh in my opinion where the leverage clearly being
wielded here is with respect to the um litigation expenses and
potential judgment which you know significant but it's to settle
scores on collateral matters that don't pertain to the underlying
God. It's the funny thing about this is people actually don't
even understand like how deep the rot goes,
right? Like I'm going to sound schizophrenic
expl like I I'm not actually going to explain what I even mean,
but like the idea that this could be okay. There's like a rot
so deep in all of these streaming communities that you have to
like tear down and rebuild.
it's like all connected. I actually have like the total skitso
like red yarn out uh trying to like map it all in my brain. Dude,
it goes so deep. Like there are so many things you have to accept
are just like total cope,
man. It's it's up, okay?
But don't worry, it'll all turn. It's all fine. It's going to
be okay. Undisputed. You can say around and find out. It leaves
a bad taste in my mouth. I don't think that's what you should
do. Uh you should be demanding these apologies on other things,
especially if you have this the sense that they're not sincere.
Why would you want an insincere acknowledgement or apology? Leaves
a >> No, no, no. Pisco, you don't understand. Oh, Pisco
needs to go watch. He needs to go to the next step here, right?
You need to go to the next step and understand that Ethan Klein
like watched this. It was like, "Oh, thank you, Casey. That was
so genuine of you. Thank you, Casey. That was so so true, Casey.
Thank you, Casey." >> Taste my mouth. I know. I This kind
of it to me lays bare what this is all about. settling scores
on unrelated collateral matters to the copyright dispute. That's
what's going on. It's laughable the notion that oh, you know,
this is really come to appreciate the the copyright statute and
and this is so important to start with that. It's it reads almost
like one of these apologies that uh Trump people uh give whenever
they he leans on them, right? >> Um I don't like it at
all. >> I do not like it at all. makes it um
>> uh actually no. It's really principally important that
Leticia James not have a second mortgage that's at a lower rate.
Okay, that's I'm I actually have a principled commitment to higher
mortgage rates for people. Okay, than what they, you know, do
by or what they deserve or what they get through buying into
a first-time homeownersh
first time homeowners discount or whatever the [__]
he did. All right. Actually, I just don't like people lying in
politics. That's why we got to go after James Comey cuz James
Comey lied to Congress. That's a really big deal. Matt Flynn,
no. Matt Flynn should get pardoned. Matt Flynn should get off
entirely. James Comey though, lying to Congress. Didn't lie to
Congress, by the way. We have to take him out. We have to take
him out, guys. I just have a principal principal commitment against
lying. It's totally not over James Comey being unwilling to to
take my orders on the Hillary Clinton stuff and on uh Crossfire
Hurricane.
God. in my opinion
seem as though and is the case the copyright stuff is a pretext,
the lawsuit is a pretext. What they want is for them to bend
the knee bend the knee on points of disagreement on accusations
made. And they can even be wrong about those accusations, but
um I don't like that. And you know, some people might say that
that's you know, [__] around and find out. It's not
how I operate. I think that >> Oh, is it is it Michael
Flynn? God damn it. It's Michael. should speak, you know, speak
their mind on these issues. Uh, as to the accusations about misogyny
or whatever,
you know, what the does it have to do with this case?
Nothing. You You got the extraction for the apology you wanted
cuz you had her by the balls.
And when you had the power to,
basically, it's a nothing.
>> Ethan is a rich local cow. He's showing us what Chrischan
Aol would have done if they had money. We the internet culture
created this. Maybe you could say that. But unfortunately, there's
only one way to get somebody like that to understand. It's everybody
making fun of them. But the issue is that there's a whole bunch
of things tied into this with regards to other communities and
other beefs. You basically have like a turf war that Hassan is
losing. There's like a son adjacent part of the internet that's
losing this turf war and everybody is trying to use this to off
that whole community and they will overlook any anything in order
to go after like certain people. It doesn't matter what it is,
right? They'll just overlook anything.
And so the fact that this is like totally disingenuous, that
it's totally disgusting, it doesn't matter
because it's it's driving in the in a directionally correct way.
It's
Gh.
There's only only public opinion can shift or can shift Ethan's
opinion on this and can shift what he does. This has to be like
totally this has to make you persona nonrada or like this entire
internet commentary space literally doesn't work. This needs
to make you persona nonrada at a base level.
And if it doesn't then this whole system this whole thing that
this internet commentary thing doesn't work.
And unfortunately, there used to be a bunch of people who were
like sort of the gatekeepers on this who were trusted to to actually
say when and when people were violating these principles and
every single one of them have totally abandoned their post, right?
They just don't call it out. They're not going to call it out
because it's so it's very enriching to just look the other way.
Actually, um I don't I really don't like the people who are getting
raped. Okay, that victim is somebody that was mean to me before.
So, actually, I don't care that they were raped. I don't care.
It's I don't want to I don't want to point it out. Listen, I
don't want to point out anything going on over there. All right.
>> Settlement. You just you're going to give away there's
no other thing but the poultry amounts that she has in her gofundme
whatever that is like what 60,000 70,000 not a ton of money.
Uh I I'm sure the litigation expenses to file the complaint,
do all this stuff was um you know something approaching it's
in the tens of thousands of dollars. It's not like he's making
a huge amount of money on it. And he said the money wasn't the
purpose either. Um it leaves a bad taste in my mouth. it the
dis disputes about misogyny, that kind of stuff. Um, I think
they should be had in the public arena.
Oh, like like you shouldn't try to solve disputes that you have
in public, like public disagreements with people. You shouldn't
try to solve those via unrelated litigation. No way. Who would
have guessed? Who would have guessed that that's principally
something every creator who engages in any form of online argumentation
should support, should be behind? Who would have guessed? Oh
my god. Very shocking that this is just the obvious point everybody
should stand on business on. Oh my goodness. And um I I I don't
like this at all about Aspen Gold.
How did I accuse this other person? You're just trying to go
through a list of things to get scalps ostensibly linked to infringement
of this content
And you include the Hassan part in there. Maybe she genuinely
feels it. I'm not saying that she doesn't. Just in case you guys
didn't see the little Easter egg on the orb. Okay, it's the thing.
Look, look at the orb. Oh, no. Nope. Why is he he Why is he off
center so much?
Oh, he's not. I Wait, what is going on? Is this just not Oh,
my browser was not the right size. That's why. Okay. All right.
That's it for the Pisco stuff. I think we've got way more to
go, though. Okay. We've got like actually so much more content
today. It's crazy.
Hold on. I got I linked a Doro clip. Speaking of
>> Speaking of people we were referencing without naming.
Okay,
>> the content nuke, >> I want to begin by stating
I take responsibility for infringing the content nuke. The lawsuit
was >> Dude, this is like an ISIS beheading
>> Yeah, exactly.
And that's awesome. I love it. This is like a This is literally
like Banana is in the room staring her down right now. not frivolous.
>> Does do we not do we not understand what the implications
are? >> Holy [__] >> This is amazing.
This is so [laughter]
>> dude. I love it. I love it. This is like an ISIS beheading
video and I love that. I LOVE COMPELLED SPEECH. I love compelled
speech. COMPELLED SPEECH. THAT'S MY FAVORITE THING. Let's go.
Let's go, guys. Let's go.
>> Uh, by the way, hold on. Just to be clear, her having
to apologize for things she had lied about or things that she
um had been find found liable for like like let's say she just
apologized for a copyright infringement. This first part I'm
okay with. Okay. Maybe not the part about her intentions with
regards to like misogyny and to deflect, but just saying like,
"Oh, I I did violate his copyright. I acknowledge that. I apologize."
That's totally fine to extract via a lawsuit. Okay. The totally
unrelated. I actually apologize for being mean to Asold about
his mom. That's insane.
That's totally insane. Okay,
regardless of whether or not I know I said when I heard it like,
"Oh, I thought it was really gross that he did this or that she
did this." I can think that and still think it's totally insane
to compel her to say that via unrelated
It's pretty goofy. It's goofy as did a particularly unhinched
response to the Casey video. Uh, let's get a time stamp. Let's
go find it. Let's go see it cuz I Oh, we we should go see it.
All right. We need that one in the archives. We need to know
what it was. Oh boy. We're going to need it. We're going to need
it real bad right now. Okay, let's see. Where's the Where is
the Asenold
reaction here? Where is it at? I might need Maybe we watch a
little more of Dior's reaction first. Okay, let's finish it.
Let's finish this up. >> And by stating, I take responsibility
for infringing the content. New >> dude, can you be a bit
more Listen, Casey, has anybody ever told you this before? Listen,
cuts, you got to smile more. You know, just give them a little
bit more
Nick would have Nick's the guy on the set who's like, "Hey, I
know you're being like double penetrated in your but could you
pretend you enjoy this and aren't in excruciating pain?" Thank
you. Hey, thanks buddy. Thanks. Thank you. More of a smile. I
think that they that would go a long way. Have you thought about
smiling before? >> Hey, with the men watching. >> Hey.
Hey, Casey. Have you thought about smiling while you're getting
double penetrated? Okay. I understand it's painful, but we're
all professionals here. Could you do your job? to begin by stating
I take responsibility for infringing the content nuke. The lawsuit
>> again uh I have to address the underlying like element
of every Ethan Klein attack against a woman. Okay, I just have
to I have to analyze it and incorporate it because it would be
disingenuous to leave it out. >> Is not frivolous. When
I said the lawsuit was frivolous and based on misogyny, it was
to garner sympathy, protect my own reputation, and retaliate
against the client. >> Oh god, this is brutal. This is
brutal.
>> This lawsuit has given me a greater understanding of
copyright protection, people's copyrights, and the importance
of protecting copyright. >> Dude, her previous statement
on this was like, I don't believe in in formal
>> I don't what I said. Ethan got her like a Taliban clip.
>> This is Yeah, it looks like this is some [__]
the Taliban would I am sorry for drawing the prophet Muhammad.
I now know that it is objectively wrong to depict the prophet
Muhammad.
Wait, hold on.
What's the bit? I literally don't know what the bit is. What's
the bit? The analogies or something. This is like coerced. Obviously,
I think of the most egregious coercion you can do, right? It's
rap. That's It's not like a bit. It's not like an anal. It's
It's literally just the obvious most egregious coercion you can
do. content nuke. I want to begin by stating I take responsibility
for infringing the content nuke. The lawsuit was not frivolous.
When I said the lawsuit was frivolous and based on misogyny,
it was to garner sympathy, protect my own reputation, and retaliate
against the CL. >> Dude, I hope the snarkers charge back
and it [__] it's it ends up being her bill anyway.
>> This lawsuit has given me a greater
>> I don't think it would be her bill. I think in that
case it would be I it might just be Ethan not receiving the funds.
I don't know. >> Of copyright protection, people's copyrights
and the importance of >> Dude, it's a total snark aside
today.
Taliban video. Oh, this is just the obvious reaction to seeing
this video, right? Like I I think everybody could come to this
like obviously just very naturally.
It's I'm sorry. It's clearly not something she would do. It's
clearly
That's what makes it so obvious. That's what This is the only
reasonable reaction. If you react like Ethan reacted, you look
like a total psychopath. You're straight up like Christian Bale
out of American Psycho. You have no human emotion. You don't
understand that this is like the most transparently
performative, transparently coerced thing that's ever happened.
And you going, that's so cool that you're so genuine about this,
Casey, that you've had a real change of heart. And unfortunately
for Ethan because of how he was using it to argue against Hassan,
I don't think that WAS A BIT I just don't think it was a bit.
I think he is actually somebody who's like
I don't know devoid of human emotion in some way. It's like the
the what is it? There's like a form of narcissism that approaches
psycho psychopathy, right? This is what Mr. Girl says Trump has,
right? It's there there's something there where like your narcissism
approaches psychopathy because of how low how little you consider
other people's emotions. It is a total
snark >> Copyrights in the online content creation community.
It is important for the entire content creation community to
respect the intellectual property rights of other creators and
I will adhere to the lessons I've learned throughout this >> I
don't think she's learned any lessons at all whatsoever. I I
literally don't think she's
>> Wait, what? I mean, this will happen if you This is
the Jay Jones theory of educating people, okay? I I hope the
worst thing happens to that person so she she learns. People
only learn through pain. Okay, this is the Jay Jones theory.
All right, this is Caseyron's version of her kids getting shot
at school to change her opinion on guns. Okay, this might actually
be legitimate. She might have a different opinion now. Oh, I
shouldn't do that. I I literally just grabbed the stove. The
stove was really hot. I'm not going to do that again. She probably
still to this day has no idea what was wrong with >> going
forward.
I also want to make clear that I did not receive any support
financial or otherwise FROM HASSAN. >> NO, [screaming]
DUDE. NO, BRO.
NO.
Oh my god,
that's funny. We always speculated that he'd kind of be a silent
like Oh, I wonder if Denims did though and she just didn't. >> Need
to respect the intellectual
It might dude
might have just been like he might have made the right call.
Okay, he might have silently decided maybe I'll make her whole
after. But she actually did totally steal this and I'm not going
to I'm not going to fund litigation there. She can't go to court
over this. She got to settle. Okay, settle first then I'll help
rewrites of other creators and I will adhere to the lessons I've
learned throughout this process going forward.
I also want to make clear that I did not receive any support,
financial or otherwise, from Hassan [__] Hassan never
even reached out to me privately to offer words of support. >> Listen,
dude, he's got another expensive dog house in Cartoon, right?
He can't be he can't be pulling the weight of all the losers
who griff off of him. >> Honestly, I found his indifference
to my suffering hurtful, especially after he hinted he might
help me behind the >> Isn't this like realistically in
a world where you want people to stand on their own opinions,
in a world where you're not trying to collude and make it so
people support you no matter what? Like like realistically, I'm
sorry, this might actually be a place where if Hassan had a principle
in this, if he wasn't just like a narcissist who doesn't help
other people, there's another way of looking at this that he's
not going to monetize people's immoral actions, right?
>> Like I understand why Destiny will go support food shops
as she lies about his case for him while she like tries to say
all the most things he doesn't want to put on record while she'll
try to say those things for him. I totally understand that. I
totally understand why he goes to bat for her. That makes total
sense to me because he wants to create an environment where you
can be monetarily incentivized to lie on his behalf or modify
your beliefs on his behalf. Right? Same with with Nicholas. Like,
right? That's what the clients are trying to do by saying Nicholas
maybe isn't after all. It's like it's what the entire online
creation space is. There's a lot of people who are willing to
slightly modify their opinions to get the patronage of a larger
creator, right? And realistically, Hassan's kind of showing here,
oh no, I'm not going to do that. I'm not going to make people
If you don't think I should be defended, if you don't think if
you can't stand on a business with your opinions, you got to
stand on your own,
>> Wait, we haven't gotten to that part yet, have we? Maybe
we have. Yeah, this is going to be the genu Yeah, the genuine
line from everybody. Um, Hassan's so gross for not supporting
this monetarily. Also, everybody who donated is so dumb for supporting
this monetarily when it was obviously going to go to Ethan.
>> Dude, I got the clip right here. I actually have the
clip. So, Hassan [__] I believe it would be here.
Yeah, this is this is Hassan indicating like wink wink nudge
nudge. I think I might help them out.
>> Give these guys Oh, socialist. Why won't he give these
guys money? Trust me, if I if I offer support, >> I just
won't know about it. >> Yeah, he just bought like a $250
Laboo for $400 on the secondary market, didn't >> You won't
know about it. Okay. Well, I guess we didn't find out about it
CUZ IT NEVER HAPPENED. THANK YOU. I appreciate >> So, he
lied. Well, that's >> didn't even call her to say dream
big. Well, buddy, >> to be fair, I wouldn't have DM'd I
wouldn't have DM'd her either. >> These guys money, trust
me. If I if I offer support, >> you won't know about it.
>> Appreciated the shout out.
>> That's so >> I also want to make clear that I
did not receive any support.
>> I I think he was trying to farm a little bit there,
but that is true. That's probably what you say in either case.
If he wasn't going to give support at all, would you want him
to say that publicly? Is that not just the general, okay, I don't
comment on stuff like that cuz I don't want to create negative
incentives.
Is that not like is that hinting that you did when you just give
the same response whether or not you want to support something?
I feel like isn't that that's got to just be the the response,
right? So people don't think they can like kind of grift and
have you financially back them. You never want to create that
Listen, but I I don't even think that's a principle he has, but
if you had that principle, that would be how you respond. I I
do still 90% the narcissist thing. Okay. But there there is like
a a small chance that that he does just think, okay, well, I
can't I can't like openly support everybody who kind of is in
my orbit, no matter what they do, no matter how egregious it
is, >> or financial or otherwise from Han >> I hate
that Adam McIntyre got there before you on this one, bro. I I
got to be honest with you, not a single person who click on Adam
McIntyre is going to be watching this. [laughter]
Wait, this is a way better idea, Kathy. Yes, hold on. I mean,
he could support her because she generally like takes his side
and defends him on the internet and that's probably important
to him is that people actually help him. He does complain about
not having motion. He does complain about being totally isolated
and quite often for somebody who doesn't want to support the
people who do come out and support him. Okay, he doesn't want
to do anything reciprocal there. I will say that. But actually
in the narcissism category of yes, she's the one who's like,
I wish Destiny could have been here and explained this to us
earlier and his son has this little like existential crisis.
That's true. He might still be holding that against her. >> I
that is a total there's honestly I think there's zero crossover
audience between me and Adam McIntyre. I saw Adam McIntyre apparently
had a video exposing a new allegation against James Charles and
if nobody else posts about it, I think he's going to get away
with it. >> clear that I >> if he's guilty I think
he'll get away with it if Adam McIntyre is the only one posting.
I also want to make clear that I did not receive any support,
financial or otherwise, from Hassan [__] >> That's
so funny, dude. All right, let's hop back into it. >> Nicholas
has to do this, by the way. Nicholas has to do this to explain.
This is a position that's totally
I'm sorry, man.
He has to do this. Um, you need you only credible people should
ever talk about this stuff on the
Adam McIntyre talking about it. It's like totally worthless,
actually. No, it's not. Even Even if Okay. Even if that were
the case,
it's like not h
has to be able to write people off because it's his entire pretense
for ignoring all the creators who like criticize him, right?
He has to be able to write people off like that. Actually, these
people are like they just want to complain about everything and
and nobody trusts them. They're not credible at all. No, I will
not talk to them. No, I will not address anything. He has to
believe this. >> It felt like he wanted to receive credit
from the public from helping me with >> Yeah, I think she's
right. I think he did. Or he went to help Casey Tron and Frogan.
No case where we went to go help Denims and Frogan and thought
Casey Tron would probably go [__] herself. >> Just
started insulting me viciously on >> She spelled it. She's
poor. Hassan didn't give her any money. >> My question
is was Casey Tron ever in the inner circle? I don't I never viewed
her as like one of the main orbiters. I viewed her as somebody
who had literally nothing else to offer, so she tried to cling
on to Hassan. I never saw them as friends, but I'm not really
sure if that's accurate. >> Hurtful, especially after he
hinted he might help me be about rape and you're hyping up a
segment on a show called Ultimate Review. >> She's broke.
She's held hostage. She's >> Jesus Christ. This guy prints
money. Holy [__] >> Whoa, buddy. >> Listen,
you can you can hate Nicholas Yorio for a lot of reasons. I'm
sure. Okay, but what you can't do ever
is say that the business that he has pursued is not profitable.
Jesus Christ. There are a lot of there are a lot of really
really like I don't know disruptive
alerts and stuff, but it's all for a lot of money. I feel like
you can't set what what is he supposed to do? Say like you need
to donate $100 for an alert? Bro, he's getting like $20, $30,
$20, $50. It's piling up. >> Say the line, funny man. >> This
is so funny. She's a product of her >> It felt like he
wanted to receive credit from the public from helping me without
providing any. As to the GoFundMe money, to the extent there
are any remaining funds after I pay my attorney's fees, I have
agreed to pay the remaining funds TO THE CLIENTS. >> NO,
Nick just thought in >> But I read on Snark that that's
not how that works. That's how it works. It can't happen like
that. The money CAN'T GO THERE. NO, I READ THAT THAT can't happen.
They told me it wasn't going to happen. They told me I was wrong.
THEY TOLD ME I said how to >> Oh, is that
is that uh you did alerts like that? You get get this cash, too.
Um nah, I don't think so. His minimum is very low, actually.
He was getting a lot of money, but the minimum is very low. He's
lucky he doesn't have a Reben Rubin. Okay, Reuben Rubin is going
to he volume he he makes sure he makes up for the donations.
He does the minimum. He does a lot of them. Okay, now I appreciate
that, but if I had five Reuben Rubins, I might have to up the
minimum. Okay, for now in a world where we've got one Reuben
Rubin, it's fine. Nick has like 10 Reuben Rubins, it looks like.
Okay, that's a rough time. That's like a ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding. No, we love Reuben Rubin here. Trust me. If I
could if I could create a world where Reuben Rubin gets the minimum
donation price over everybody else. And if I ever were to up
it, he still gets the minimum. I would do that, okay? Cuz we
love Reven Rubin here. >> Oh, it works. OH MY GOD. NO.
NO.
>> OH, RIGHT. So he's saying, "Oh, Snark said the money
couldn't be transferred." Well, I mean, I think obviously it
could, right? The money is transferred to her. I don't even think
GoFundMe has in their toos that it has to really be used for
the thing that you say it was used for, right? I think it just
transfers essentially they they have no way of enforcing that.
So, it just transfers to the person who ran the GoFundMe and
it's under their recgnizance, right? Like they they just whether
or not they do it is up to them. So, you give the money to them,
right? And then I think it's up to you to civily sue them if
you want. Like if somebody donated Caseyron and she doesn't like
that she g that she gave this up in the lawsuit. I think they
could maybe try to sue her for fraud or something. Yeah. So I'm
trying to think why would anybody argue that you couldn't do
that though? That you couldn't like transfer the money from the
GoFundMe to somebody else. I'm trying to think if I argued that.
Did I argue that? I don't think I did. Maybe I argued that you
couldn't get that from a judge. Like a judge wouldn't rule that
way. But money's money like money ultimately the thing that happens
is money is fungeable, right? Essentially what Ethan did was
he accepted a settlement that probably was lower than the amount
of money he could have demanded reasonably just so he could have
the the additional providence of saying, "Oh, I got the money
from the snarkers,
right?"
That's like that's what he wanted was that it just it drives
that he doesn't feel like he was harmed. He doesn't feel like
anything wrong was happen. It's just people criticizing him.
He doesn't like he he's attacking these communities that criticized
him. It's why he brings up the Ana and Idubbbz stuff, right?
It's all that it's it's all that this is about the whole time.
I really like him. [laughter] Why,
>> dude? Thank Thank you to Snark for raising all this
money that goes directly into the client's pockets. >> It
felt like he wanted >> Dude, and the best part is that
only one has gone down. So Ethan can now direct these funds into
the other lawsuits. So now he's using Snark money to them up
into this [__] sign, >> dude. They're using
the money that they gave to Caseyron to go up Froggen. That's
that's almost funnier than my suggestion, which I think they
he should buy a watch after every single one of them. and name
them after every lawsuit. Right. I I I personally think he should
take whatever money that he gets from Caseyron and then buy a
a nice Swiss horological time piece and name them after them
>> to receive credit from the public for him helping me
without providing any. As to the GoFundMe money to the extent
there are any remaining funds after I pay my attorney's fees,
I have agreed to pay the remaining funds to the client.
>> Recognizance is only is a term I only know about being
led out of jail. Yeah. Uh you get a PR bond, right? You're released
on your personal recgnizance as in like it's your responsibility
to fulfill whatever obligations you have. Right?
Recognizance.
Is that how you spell it? A bond by which a person undertakes
before a court or magistrate to observe some condition especially
to appear when sub summoned. So it's basically like you're taking
that money. This is what I thought, right? Conditional pledge
of money made by a person before a court. Oh, it's I guess it's
not before a court. I'm using it sort of anecdot anecdotally,
but it's the same thing. is a correct use.
>> The funds will not go any to anyone else, including
Denims or Froen to defend their lawsuit. >> Oh no. >> For
the record, I have agreed to cooperate with the in their litigation
against the H3 snark MODS FOR >> OH NO. >> THE POSSIBLE,
>> DUDE. SHE'S [__] FULL. Oh wow. Oh >> My
live stream. >> Dude, this is a this is a diabolical
victory. I didn't even know that. >> I think Ethan should
ask Sorry. I think Nick should ask Ethan. Wait, does she have
stuff that she can actually divulge there or did you just make
it a condition of her of the settlement that she say she will
help that she says she will help? Because if you notice, there's
a bunch of private information in here, right, that she includes
that doesn't really there's no reason she would just do it for
herself. So why didn't Ethan Hey, all of this is the truth, guys.
Wait, why did she say a bunch of facts, but then around the H3
Stark mod stuff? She doesn't say, "Oh, and I have proof that
the Stark mods coordinated with streamers." She doesn't say anything
like that, right? She doesn't say that. Oh, that's very curious,
isn't it? She just says she will testify and help. Huh.
>> Interesting. And oh, >> that was so bad. >> To
the extent that I am able. I will offer my support, including
testifying under oath to everything I HAVE JUST >> YO,
H3 SNARK, THIS ONE'S FOR YOU.
>> Oh my goodness. This is like this is like we live in
a timeline where slavery like basically the civil war was never
lost and you have like one of the strongest civil rights advocates
from the north from the north, okay, goes to the south and starts
doing minstal shows like like of their own free will. All right,
you have like a super racist south in the United States, a super
like free north, one of the strongest civil rights people, okay,
goes from the north to the south. That's what we're watching
right now. And they just start doing minstal shows for some reason.
They just become a total caricature of the things they used to
mock, right? for the people they used to mock. It's actually
cataclysmic. It's very sad.
>> Is ridiculous. >> So, she loses basically none
of her own money. She gives Ethan all the Snark money. She now
turns on the Snark people, Denim's and Froggen essentially, right?
To go now assist Ethan in testifying in the lawsuit against the
Snark, which by the way, uh Denim's also kind of already did
that too. Like Denim's already kind of stabbed. There is no um
no help to the Snark people. No, they're not jumping out to help
any >> talk to Nick. Tell him he's a Dixie Southerner.
Oh, I'd love to talk to >> And you're hyping up a dude
who has a segment on a show called Ultimate >> So, the
Snarkers have donated money. >> My next stream and say
he will did not donate because he knew the money would go to
Israel. I mean, Ethan, [laughter] >> I actually have a
clip from >> And you're hyping up a dude who has a segment
on a show called Ultimate Review. So, >> Ethan really has
earned the title of Lex >> Yeah, I think Yeah, dude. I
I think so. Do I have the button ready for that one?
>> Yes, dude. Dude, it's Lex Juther.
>> I don't mind this with the Negila. Okay, it's got the
Okay, wait. That's so
>> I feel like he's just giving us an awesome meme. I hope
he plays that somewhere openly. Okay, I'm sorry. I want to steal
that cuz that is going to be so awesome.
That's That's got so many uses. That's got so many uses.
Oh my god. Um, you know what else is great? He doesn't track
his stream recording, so donos are heard in the edited videos,
too.
Oh,
well, that's fine.
That's unfortunate for him. But wait, why doesn't he do that?
Wouldn't that be pretty easy? >> That's so [__]
>> You want to hard style have a gila? No, I I like the
old version to be honest with you. It's much more You need the
right instruments. That is That's a little too upbeat. Okay.
>> Was promised to Ethan 3,000 years ago, >> dude.
So the snarkers donated to Casey Trod who sold them out who has
agreed to testify against them to the H3 Empire long may they
reign. >> So their money is going to be used to prosecute
themselves and the person they gave it to is going to testify
on behalf of
this is so terrible for that.
They're so done. They're so done.
>> Stated to help their cause. >> I also want to
take the opportunity started in Twitter. >> Take the opportunity.
The narrative will now be that she was always a backstabber.
Nobody likes her. Denim's always got a bad vibe from her. >> You
know what? I just want to shout out
>> The narrative shouldn't be that. Hassan literally said
explicitly not that. He said, "Oh, whatever she has to say about
me is totally fine. Don't get mad at her for that." Right. Yeah.
This This is the issue is if she had something to testify with,
there's no reason she couldn't say it now. Right. This is the
we're witnessing something very akin to what we see from Destiny,
right? Actually, when I have to talk about the things I allege,
uh, I have a court case. When I have to talk about the things
other people are doing, um, they need to publish all of their
information now. Yes. Yes. Yes. Yes. Great. Good stuff. But which
what she's doing here is all of this. She leaks the Hassan thing.
She leaks what else? Oh, she she does all these private like
apologies that she could just do somewhere else, right? That
are totally like orthogonal to the lawsuit. And then then to
top it all off, she goes, "Um, I'm not going to say what I have
on the H3 Snark people, but I will testify about them for Ethan."
Like, okay,
listen. I I understand all the things you need to do for propaganda.
I see them all here. >> [__] H3 Snark, Denims,
Frogan, we did it, guys. We saved Gaza. Yes, we did it. WE SAVED
GAZA. THEY'RE ALL GOOD NOW. >> oath to everything I have
just stated to help their cause. I also want to take the opportunity
to acknowledge other
No. Um, with my stream there, it's not like this, right? Nick's
obviously got like a bigger operation. He'll probably do if somebody
points it out to him enough, but I Sorry, soapbox. Sorry, I actually
was responding to you without highlighting. Um, I don't like
upload my stuff for Riley to grab. I probably could. I could
probably set that up, but I just don't upload it for Riley to
grab. It might It also might not make sense. Like for me, it's
not this obnoxious that I get these constant
these constant alerts, you know? I do like a I do calls to action
like I've only done it once this stream. I do them like once
every two or three hours usually. Um so it's just it's not happening
anywhere near as much with if it was happening this much it'd
be a little too annoying. >> Conduct and bad behavior I
have exhibited online. >> For example, weaponizing the
death the death of Asmin Gold's mother was in >> Oh my
god. Now we wait now. Now now she's apologizing to Asmin Gold.
>> I just saw Ke's tweet >> Ethan wrote that into
the law. That's crazy. take the opportunity to acknowledge other
misconduct and bad behavior I have exhibited online. >> I
didn't know we were supposed to submit our apologies.
>> What the? >> For example, weaponizing the death
the death of Admin Gold's mother was inexcusable. I should know
better because I have three disabled people that rely on me.
>> What's the name of yourself? >> Keemstar Orbiter
Nick Oreo
Oreo
>> forward. I will do better. I also want to apologize
to the crew
>> three podcast. >> Oh my god, it's everybody. Everybody,
bro. Everybody is here. >> Oh no. What am I going to do,
>> dude? Ultimate snarkside. This is so >> AB and
Olivia. >> Holy [__] She's apologizing. [__]
Is that what's in the crystal ball? Candace's brain worms. No.
No.
The crystal ball has hold on. Let me Let me go see.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. I've got a meme for this. Hold
on. Hold on. Are you holding on? Are you holding on? Are you
holding on? Hold on. Hold on. Well, there's this one. Top Bronson
made this one.
Look,
we're reviewing streams.
Todd Bronson had some suggestions. We could do little memes for
this. Okay, we could do easily add little memes into the crystal
ball. Okay, good times. Good. Good times.
>> Nicholas Oreo. >> We in this [__]
son. >> Listen, I'm not going to go on the Klein's parade
here. I'm sure it goes its smoothest if everybody is nice to
Casey Tron. That being said, this is not an Ethan Klein run show
and I still hate her and I did not get paid by H3 Snark. So,
just to be clear, just to be clear, I still hate her. I give
her zero credit for a gun to her head apology. Okay. Um I I I
I there's not a ounce of sympathy coming to me from a person.
>> This is why like just saying, "Oh, don't do that." is
not quite enough. You actually need to like create consequences
or like like some kind of consequences for people not like respecting
that, right? in some way. Like at at minimum, you should take
some steps to try to prevent it. Like if if you do this, if I
see evidence of you doing this, I'll ban you from my communities,
right? For for Ethan specifically, if you actually wanted to
have anything happen. If you just want the performance of saying,
"Well, don't go harass her while knowing that it will absolutely
still happen, then you say what you said, who is staring down,
she's literally staring down a RPG that's pointed at her in her
house." Okay? I have absolutely no sympathy for her. You won't
hear a lick of any from me, but if you want to, that's totally
fine. name of the the guy Keemstar Orbiter Nick Oreo. Mr. Oreo
>> Asmin Gold does not accept it. I know that too.
>> Yeah, I understand from Ethan's perspective who just
did this this agreement with her and all this stuff and he just
won big and obviously >> many people are telling me that
is a great day for the unemployed. >> That's what [laughter]
I hear. Truly a great day. >> I don't know what that that
laugh was. I kind of just sounded like Mr. Boss >> day
Trump. >> Holy [__] >> Nick just >> total
snark demolition. [laughter] >> Yeah. Yeah. So, again,
just to kind of get that out there, I get if Ethan Klein really
maybe he's like really totally accepting of the apology or uh
maybe it just goes smoother if things are if people are nice
and say positive things, but this is not an extension of his
show and I'm going to still be an So, fair >> I apologize
for calling them cowards for not quitting their jobs. [laughter]
>> That was a shameful attack on two people who deeply
care about Palestine. >> You're a coward cuz you refuse
to get one, loser. >> Stop sober.
>> You know what? You know what needs to happen? Dude,
I can't wait to green screen her into new and funny places. You
know, she always films these things behind a blank wall. >> Is
this really >> Where should we put her when she gives the
speech? >> Palestinian people, AB along with his wife,
Lena.
>> Oh, hold on. Do we have the inside of any IDF torture
rooms? Have there been investigations? Do we have pictures of
those? Let's go.
>> Can we Can we go put her in the Oh, what is it? The
IDF office just outside of Oh, where did Where did Ela go? Okay.
Where did Ela go in her night raid? Put her in that IDF office.
Okay, we just want to ask you some questions >> for the
Palestinian people. >> Oh my god, bro. This is ridiculous.
I recommend watching Nicholas. >> Dude, EVERY SENTENCE
THERE'S ANOTHER >> I've never looked at the leftovers Reddit
till today. This is hilarious. The amount of unbridled rage in
these comments is gold. >> Oh my god, bro. >> Ke's
tweeting on Nicholas. >> Holy mother of God.
>> Trump, Battlefield 6, and Zootopia 2 are back. Hassan
Kron and Idubbbz are losing. All is died in the world. >> I
can't believe it's December right now and we're still here. I
can't We're still here, guys. We're still covering this. It's
still interesting, at least to me. And there's still nukes dropping
every week. Um, just for context, cuz we kind of got locked and
loaded here on this for a little while. We have the Snark Reddit.
We have Ethan's response. We've got Hassan's new statement. We're
going to be covering the entire thing. All right, but we're >> I
feel like I want to laugh at him for this, but you know what?
Sometimes you just you hit a flow, okay? And it just feels normal.
It just feels good to just keep hitting the same stuff over and
over again. Okay, I understand it. I get it. I want to say it's
like boring and tired. I don't think I've ever been on a flow
that long. For me, it's like a week. I don't think I've ever
been on like a fourmon flow, a six-month flow where it's just
like this is going to be my content again and again and again
and again until we all die till the heat death of the universe.
But I do
Keemstar Orbiter Nick Oreo. Mr. Oreo
>> between I Dude, this is an unreactable stream. Not cuz
the commentary is like bad. You can you can take or leave Nicholas's
commentary. I don't think he's a bad commentator. I think he's
usually funny. But it's not because the commentary is bad. It's
cuz I'm pausing. I'm commenting and then he gets like eight donations.
So he pauses for the donations. It's It's just going like
we're going to react to a threeminute segment, three-minute video.
It's going to take two hours.
Wild. All right. I We'll look up the Asenold thing. I think he
already published a video and then maybe that'll be it for today.
I I'll leave the other stuff for tomorrow. We can do the the
Connor versus Pisco stuff tomorrow. We can do
I think we can do everything tomorrow. Okay. Give me a second.
As Bongold,
where is it? >> You're not real. >> You're not real.
>> Casey Tron went and made an apology. So, here we go.
Right here. So part of I guess the settlement with Ethan is that
there is an apology.
>> I'm told you were looped content daily until January
20th. I don't even know what that means. Looped on what? >> That
she had to make.
Y'all ready for this? She had to apologize and she went live
and did it. Here we go. >> And by stating I take her
>> the FBI jacket to close out the night. Why? I don't
want the FBI jacket right now. I like pondering the orb, bro.
You couldn't even do >> I Well, hold on. This was It wasn't
Yeah, that was one of the moments though. Absolutely. But that
she said before that you were looped content daily until January
20th. As in before that you were looped content >> live.
She had to go and Oh my god.
>> And you didn't even start it at the beginning of the
video. Look at THIS HERE. WATCH. >> OH, the Cash Patel
thing. Oh, Kerski, I get it. I thought you were like referencing
the cash thing. I get it. >> Real quick, >> wait.
Let me let me pull this up. >> You know what? You know
what? Just for you, Kerski. Yes, we will do the we will do that
before we end, okay? Because I I noticed you post some content
for me and I don't always get to it and I want to incentivize
that kind of behavior. So, if you post content content links,
I will take the time to go over it, especially if you're here
on stream. So, >> pull this up. Watch real quick. You see
this? It's
>> like you were the Destiny after hours place before January
20th. I mean, I did a whole bunch of different content. Destiny
was the topic maybe what one night in five like it was it was
where a bunch of people came who were Destiny orbiters but we
didn't discuss Destiny all the time that wasn't like the topic
all the time that would be really boring >> one second
in >> it was it was actually way less egregious than what
Nick's content is now like unironically when it was the DGG afterhour
stream it was way less egregiously like Destiny centered than
Nick's content is H3 centered. It's kind of funny. You couldn't
even start it at the beginning of the video. >> And by
stating, I take responsibility for infringing the content nuke.
I want to begin by stating I take responsibility for infringing
the content nuke. The lawsuit was not frivolous. When I said
the lawsuit was frivolous and based on misogyny, it was to garner
sympathy. Protect >> Oh, boy.
>> Yep. True. >> Very true. So true. It can. >> Yep.
Yep. Be more true. >> Sorry. Sorry. I
uh I'll be honest. I think my reaction style is most similar
to Asmin Golds, so I feel like a little bad for making fun of
him. Like it's actually most similar to his. I pause quite a
bit just for like my verbal reaction.
Probably more than the average streamer. I don't know. So I I
shouldn't make fun of him that much, okay? Cuz I do this >> my
own reputation and retaliate against the client's
>> this lawsuit. >> Exactly. Retal. Wait. No. No.
Retaliate.
There's no retaliation. You were never attacked by them. You
never got attacked by Ethan.
You attacked Ethan. He didn't even know who the you were.
Retaliate >> has given me a greater understanding of
>> You don't have predictable catchphrases.
I used to, didn't I? I feel like I I feel like I did. You're
so mean to yourself. What do you mean? That's not even mean.
You have to be Listen, here's the thing.
A lot of people think Asmin Gold is a really great streamer.
Okay, he is a good streamer. Saying I have like similar qualities
to Asold isn't necessarily denigrating myself. Depends on what
those qualities are. He has some admirable admirable qualities.
He's one of the biggest entertainers on planet Earth. Of course,
he has good qualities. >> Copyright protection. >> I'm
not mean. >> People's copyrights and the importance of
protecting copyrights in the online content creation community.
>> Thank you, Gregor. This is brutal. You You have a similar
style but are a less successful financially successful version
of Asmin. God damn it. It is important for the entire content
creation community to respect the intellectual property rights
of other creators and I will adhere to the lessons I've learned
throughout this process going >> No, you won't. You're
going to keep watching YouTube videos. >> Oh, I used to
say sweet dreams. I used to say that. That's true. I I should
do that again. Oh, when I first started the stream like the hello
hello, it's like really actually quite important to bookend streams
with like stuff like that. It's actually really important. Like
I I want to say mimetically that probably sounds like nerdy or
like overanalyzed. It's actually quite important to have things
like that like in jokes, community things, things you're consistent
on. Absolutely. Yeah. >> In movies while you were asleep.
You're going to be doing this probably tomorrow >> forward.
I also want to make clear that I did not receive any support
financial or otherwise from Hassan [__] Hassan never
even reached out to me privately to off uh >> based he
don't know who you are.
You're a bottom feeder >> for words of support.
>> Damn. Speak. >> Yeah, of course. Why would he?
You a weirdo trying to sniff his clothes. Remember that clip?
>> I have to get really in there. But there's definitely
this >> God damn.
I'm going to say it.
It's Herodite in two years. Okay, I'm going to play.
>> NO. NO. STOP. STOP. STOP. STOP.
>> DING. Want to talk to you? Not so Herodite enters Destiny's
bedroom in two years. Jesus weird ass. >> Jesus [__]
Christ.
>> This is weird.
>> What's wrong with you?
>> You treat a person this way. He doesn't deserve to be
treated that way. It's
>> to talk to invade somebody's personal space. That was
on camera. She did the
never even reached out to me privately to offer words of support.
>> She's sniffing where his ass. She was not sniffing his
pillow and he did not even message you. >> Whose bed was
that? Well, I mean,
I assume the the implication is that that's Hassan's bed. It's
got to be where Hassan was sleeping. Girls get away with some
wild, bro. People criticize XQC when he like moves his camera
with his nose and like sniffs somebody's chair and then Caseyron
does that. Nobody comments. What the [__] Actually,
I'm guessing there probably was blowback to that. I'm guessing
a bunch of people were like, "Rverse the roles." Train wrecks
probably react to that. was like, "UH, THINK ABOUT IT. IF A GO
if a girl did this, sorry, if a guy did this to a girl, he'd
be so creepy. I can't even do this. This is beautiful. That doesn't
sound like train at all. I I can't even do this. Let me tell
you something. Let me tell you something." Okay. I can't even
do this. I I don't know. I I I haven't watched enough train to
get it right. That wasn't a good train voice. I'll figure it
out. >> Make clear that I do respect the
>> Listen up. ual property rights of other creators and
I will adhere to the lessons I've learned throughout this process
going forward.
I also want to make clear that I did not receive any support
financial or otherwise from Hassan [__] Hassan never
even reached out to me privately to offer words of support. Speaking
honestly, I found his indifference to my suffering hurtful. >> His
indifference to your suffering? Oh my god. But you want to see
Oh, bro. What? Yeah. Yeah. You thought you were on the team.
Oh my god.
>> Again, just the uh >> I how should I put this?
Maybe for this one part, if he interprets the other parts as
sincere.
Um maybe I'll have a problem with it. This part actually I do
think is probably sincere as much as it's read like the hostage
letter. I'm sure she felt off put that Hassan didn't help at
all. I'm sure she felt like put off rather put off that Hassan
didn't help. put off that Hassan didn't send any encouraging
words, >> especially after he hinted he might help me behind
the scenes.
absolutely
based. Wow.
>> Did you just watch that part twice? So, you went out
there and you were fighting, you were waving around his flag
and he didn't even know who you
>> Damn. That's sad. That's really sad. >> I mean,
he obviously knows who she is. I'm pretty sure they've had conversations.
She was like the topic of discussion in his discord for quite
a while, right? Um, so obviously obviously he knows who she is.
I would say,
she is not on the team. Okay, she's not on the team. And
I'm genuinely sitting here thinking like it doesn't matter what
he does. There's a criticism there, I guess. Like if he did fund
her, could you imagine if he funded her? Oh. Uh, people's just
going to fund people who harass Ethan Klein. He's actually just
funding people who harass Ethan Klein. It's so disgusting,
right? Like I It just goes both ways, but whatever. >> It
felt like he wanted to receive credit from the public from helping
me without providing any.
>> She called him a virtue signaler. Oh my god. Oh wow.
>> As to the GoFundMe money, to the extent there are any
remaining funds after I pay my >> There won't be. There
won't be >> her fees. I have agreed to pay the remaining
funds to the clients. The funds will not go any. >> So
all of the people that hated Ethan that donated their hard-earned
money, their wage slave money
is going to Ethan Klein's IDF
Israeli Defense Fund. You have You have
Dude, Asminold is so much funnier than Ethan and Nick.
People wonder why people wonder why Asmin Gold like makes the
big bucks. Okay, he's actually just a better streamer. That's
the fact. The fact of the matter, okay, mechanically, he's like
Dave Chappelle. I might not like this the trans topics when Dave
Chappelle goes off on them, but mechanically he can still make
people laugh, okay? He can deliver a [__] joke. >> Yes.
Yes. Asold is a better streamer. He's absolutely a better streamer
than those people. >> I mean, everybody likes the redistribution
of wealth, right?
you have redistributed
people who are, you know, very like, you know, you try to say,
"Oh, a pro Palestine." So, you you've redistributed their money
directly to somebody who I think the better joke here, okay,
if we're really on point, the better joke here is, oh, you just
uh you just donated money to the UN, okay, for for Palestinian
aid. Guess what? That's help now. That's help now. All right.
The terrorists got it. You donated. You thought you were donating
to help Palestinians eat, but that's that's turning into rockets,
buddy. Okay. >> Who do you think is an Israeli
uh Zionist with a wife who was in the IDF?
>> And you're going to be giving them all of your money.
So everybody who >> to be honest, you all pay taxes anyway.
That's already happening. Not even
>> Remember what I said before about how Oh, I don't care.
At least they did it of their own free will this time. The taxes
are compelled. The taxes you send to them, those are compelled.
At least these people got to make a decision. >> People
are donating to this girl because it's all just more money for
Ethan. >> No, that I'm sorry. His joke is still
How about that? How about that? I remember you saying that. That's
right. >> How about that? >> Oh, that's right. I
just sometimes
>> I I do now actually applaud Ethan though for because
he has he has simultaneously like shown us that this was his
only goal was to like actually just run a narrative on the internet.
That's the only thing the lawsuits were for. It wasn't for like
he felt like his copyright was violated. He was like significantly
harmed and he needed that money back. Was nothing like that.
It was essentially all
him
just wanting to run his like narrative online, run it, get content.
It's really all it was, right? That's I don't know. But but like
the content was smart. Demanding that you get the GoFundMe money
instead of like some larger sum. That was smart. He's going to
make way more money for all of for him and all of his friends
by getting that GoFundMe money. Like I guarantee you if he could
have chosen between $200,000, $300,000 and that GoFundMe money
like 50, he would have just taken the GoFundMe money. That's
what he wanted, man. That was like the that was the big prize
here. Sometimes it feels so >> I feel like almost even
more than the apology video. Damn. What do you think this agreement
possibly could have been? He wrote the script or gave her certain
talking points. I'm guessing he wanted he had things he wanted
in an apology and that basically he wanted her to like video
or write a script and then he would approve it.
Yeah. Like you you run through these things and then I'll like
approve and then we we agree or we mutually agree on like what
the output would be.
But hold on. I have not seen I didn't actually get a chance to
see the claim. Somebody told me that he said he would um that
he said he had like final say on what would be accepted for the
apology, but I haven't seen him claim that. So, if we have a
clip on that somewhere, I would appreciate it while even I don't
believe
>> It's so poetic. I said it was going to
>> Didn't she repeatedly say no GoFundMe money would go
towards the settlement in her previous videos? I have no idea.
Didn't watch them. Like anybody knew this was going to happen.
Like I is it. Yeah. So there it is. >> Anyone else including
Denims or Frogan to defend their lawsuits. >> Oh, he didn't
even Wait, he didn't even give them money either. So he didn't
give any of them money. Good. He shouldn't have. Honestly, they're
stupid as Oh, he
he's uh what do you call it? He's defending or he's saying this
about Hassan. I think he is mur I think he misheard here, right?
He thinks that this is Yeah. Yeah. He he misheard. Um, listen,
he was just pausing on his position. He shouldn't have given
them any money. You think he should have paid you money and cover
your bills because you want to act like a nasty ass talking about
Oh, yeah. I'm going to go and Oh, interesting. Ethan Klein took
a totally different approach to this one, didn't he? Asold actually
kind of based here again. Asigold actually has some like modus
operandi. Asold is not a I keep seeing it over and over again.
Okay. like he knows. Oh, should I virtue signal and say that
Husan should have paid these people? No. These people and you
shouldn't incentivize people to to like be for you. Like if I
have the opinion that you're being a total like your behavior
is indefensible, obviously I'm not going to argue Hassan should
monetize that. Very interesting. >> And re-upload this
so you can watch it ethically. Well, what's ethical about giving
them all your money?
You raised funds from your broke loser fans and now you're giving
it to a
Talk about ethical. How about that? Honestly, like Yeah. It it
How good it would be if Ethan donates the GoFundMe money to Palestine?
Yeah.
Now, can [laughter]
he find that funny or interesting? Yeah. Does she get sued again
for misappropriation of funds? No. For the record, I have agreed
to cooperate with the clients in their litigation against the
H3 Snark mods for promoting my live stream. >> So Ethan
is going direct. So So now she's on Ethan's side. See, Israel
isn't so bad after all.
>> Wow, that's a crazy takeaway. >> That's crazy.
Oh boy.
>> To the extent that I am able, I will offer my support,
including testifying under oath to everything I have just This
would be the >> I love that. I love that Asmin Gold um
Ethan Klein sits here constantly sending out signals that he
wants to like collab with Asmin Gold. Hey, hey, make sure you
apologize to Asmin Gold here. Hey, hey, actually care about Asmin
Gold. And Asold sits here is like these these totally genocidal
Israelis aren't so bad sometimes. Actually, these these people
aren't so bad sometimes. Look at him totally genociding Casey
Tron's entire online reputation. It's pretty awesome, these Israelis.
the point where I would play the um [snorts] the song that they
play on Instagram, but I don't know what the name of it is. So,
just imagine it in your head.
>> against the H3 snark mods for promoting my live stream
to the extent that I am >> I will offer my support, including
testifying under oath to everything I have just >> Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Actually, actually, yeah. What
is his algorithm that he keeps having that show up in like comedic
Instagram reels? Wait, what? Wait. Huh? [laughter] Asminold.
What are they serving you exactly? This is what happens when
you constantly search for Nick Fuentes clips on Instagram. Okay.
Somehow I just keep getting all these funny memes about with
Havilla playing in the background.
109 countries. Oh boy. Wow. >> To help their cause. >> I
also want to take the opportunity to acknowledge their misconduct
and bad >> absolutely roached out.
Cleaned out. This is beautiful.
You think a lawyer or chat GBT wrote this? I bet a lawyer wrote
it.
>> Behavior I have exhibited online. >> That's a
lot. >> For example, weaponizing the death the death of
Asmin Gold's mother was
>> It sure was. That's why it's not getting excused. Apology
not accepted. You did this because of a lawyer. Okay. Every other
statement in here is sincere and I will engage with it as owed
sincere. That statement? No. You only did this because of a lawyer.
Nope. I should know better because >> it's 1 minute 30.
1 hour 3030. >> There you go. That's Hassan's [clears throat]
response there. I'm acting like Israel.
>> Did we cut it out? >> Checkmate. Checkmate. >> Zion.
Did >> I miss it? >> Hassan wins again.
>> Oh, hold on. You didn't like a time stamp and I'm at
my own thing. Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
>> Not so now. That being said, let's look at the apology.
What? Nate, >> it's almost live. I'm telling you to 30
around 30 seconds. It's going [laughter] >> Oh, it's not
out yet. >> Oh, nobody's seen it yet. >> Yeah, click
it. [snorts]
>> Oh, okay. Okay. So, let's watch it. She's doing a live
stream. Now, of course, this was the reason I say that is cuz
I I have seen it
and um and I just want to say that um >> like I said, it's
very heartfelt and it's very meaningful and I appreciate it.
So, we're going to enjoy this here and uh >> wait, where
are you? >> Watch it all together and move on all
>> she can see.
Okay, here.
>> Wait. Hour. Hold on. Yeah. Hour 3030. But now here it
is. And we still haven't seen him claim it. So, hour 30. >> Did
I miss it by like a second? I I genuinely from my heart I want
you guys to know that I accept her apology and I do believe it
was made insincere and I do hope that she moves on. I just want to
make a very clear message to them. This is more about smart than
her. But I can say anything I want about her, but I choose not
to because I'm a big I'm a big man. I'm a big I'm very mad. But
that being said now
>> Okay, hold on. Hold on. I think is the time stamp just
off here? Maybe it's just like this. >> Go ahead. So
now it's together. But before I do, I want to thank Sean for
being a good um a good faith negotiator. I think going into this
case we both came out of this happily surprised that we're able
to kind of put this behind both us and move on amicably. So I
do want to thank Case I think ultimately her apology was heartfelt
and sincere and I really appreciate everything she said and I
want to say thank you in case
for all of us and I just wish you I wish you all the best and
I
>> actually hold on wait wait wait
that might actually be relevant. Hold on.
Why couldn't she do that? [laughter] I guess Hold on. I think
probably I'm guessing because of the lawsuit there'd be some
kind of implied license there
>> Now that being said, send this snarkling
>> The one check. >> He'd already saying he'd seen
it before it was live does not mean
that doesn't mean he had say sorry. The thing that got said before
was that he had final say on whether or not it was a thing. I
still believe that's the case, but I thought we had that from
him. I don't see it there. Him saying he saw it before is not
him saying he had to approve it. They're different. He looks
insane when he sped up. He does. He does indeed. Okay. So, we
don't have that on the record. I didn't see it on the record.
That's why I was like, "Oh, I need to see it just so I can know
whether or not I can claim it and I can't claim it." So, it's
wrong. >> I have three disabled people that rely on me
>> moving forward. I will do better.
>> I won't I won't absolutely not. Apology not accepted.
>> Man, I wonder if Aasmin Gold knows the the track record
how people do when they adopt this thing. the the having you
money and being like the totally like I reject societal judgment
entirely. It doesn't always work for people like usually these
people end up being quite alone and quite like depressed.
Okay, I'm thinking like Notch is one like it feels like he's
going down like a Notch route. Maybe Notch wasn't a content creator
so maybe he didn't have like fans to the same extent. Maybe it's
totally different, but I get the feeling that he's like going
down that route where he's just going to like totally reject
acting like a good person in any way and and just like sort of
wallow in this. I I hope he doesn't. It's just not even not cuz
he doesn't have to, right? Like I get it if you want to make
money. I don't know. I get why you think so, but check out SocialBlade
for H3 pod. It's really bad.
Uh Link, I know what you're doing. I know what people like you
do. you apologize and sue. >> But hold on. It's not even
that he can't do this. Like obviously he makes content. I think
he's a good content creator. He uh he makes a lot of money. I
just don't think you have to do this. You could like Oh, maybe
maybe let it go with Casey. Again, I go back and forth on the
like, "Well, you said that about his mom." I wouldn't let that
go. I I would be really really spiteful about that personally.
Okay. Good relationship with my parents. You say that [__]
about my parents, we're going to have a problem. You know, obviously
I don't talk about my parents. I haven't had them like I haven't
talked about neither of them have died so I never haven't talked
about it on stream neither of them been featured on stream so
it's a little different but yeah I wouldn't let that go okay
that would be for peace whenever you're in a position of weakness
and then you antagonize aggress people whenever you're in a position
of
oh this is the monthly gain views for the H3 podcast so going
to 2023
Yeah,
yeah, yeah. This is about what you'd expect.
I guess you could argue
that around October 7th, they had the split with Hassan's community
that they had this big community like backing them and but I
don't know, that's probably
where you expect this all to go. Yeah. Yeah, I get it. Although,
I will say the people left behind here are going to be like way
more entrenched, way more behind this kind of content, right?
You know what I'm saying? So like these people are probably like
all of the donators, all the people who are like financially
incentivizing like this behavior. So I'm guessing that these
people are way more entrenched. He's probably not making like
less money. Probably feels like more supported now. I'm guessing.
Anyway, keep going. Not with this guy though. This guy. This
is only getting This is only This is This is for Casey Tron.
I'm going let y'all know this. This is the best it's ever going
to be right now.
This is the best it's ever going to be for her.
Dude, we started talking about how people are cartoonishly cartoonishly
villains, okay? Cartoonishly evil. Dude, he's straight up like,
"I'mma ruin your life, [__] I'm coming for you, [__]
I'm I'mma stop you out. I'mma stomp you out." What the hell?
What the hell, man? This guy's crazy.
How about that?
This not an apology? Well, I don't know. This guy's crazy. Never
take the high road. I never take the I'd never Uh-uh. Nope. Never
take the high road. >> Also want to apologize to the crew
of the H3 podcast, particularly AB and
>> I apologize for calling them cowards for not quitting
their jobs. That was a >> Oh, wow. How about that?
Wow. Yeah. So, you were actually wrong about this.
So, this is what I think is funny. I think what's funny about
this is that, you know, she can't keep her mouth shut
and you are going to go back on this and you are going to, you
know, signal and imply and you're going to up again. And I also
I know she doesn't know this, but this put her in a position
for something that's going to happen in the future. I don't know
if Ethan knows this. I think Ethan does know this, but I I'm
not going to say what it is because I want it to happen. Wait,
what? Hold on. Hold on, dude. Is there Hold on. Is there like
more lawsuits that are coming for these people? Oh, boy. >> For
something that's going to happen in the future.
>> Uh-oh.
I wonder what this is. What's Asmin Gold's proclivity for for
totally like vague posting and not coming about. I don't know
with Asmin Gold. I know with a lot of other people when they
vague post, they don't mean, but with uh with with Asmin Gold,
I don't know how often he vague posts. Like the other vague posting
he was doing was around Miskf. And it turned out he completely
wrecked Miskf's life. So
whoa whoa whoa whoa. [laughter] That's the last one I know of.
And she admitted to stuff that could bite her in the f bite her
in the butt in the future. She admitted to what stuff? What do
you mean? I don't know if Ethan knows this. I think Ethan does
know this. But I I'm not going to say what it is because I want
it to happen. I do. And I know if if I say what it is, it'll
lower the probability of it happening. I understand. I apologize
for vague posting, but I promise you it will be worth it. Do
you remember last time I was vague posting?
>> I do. I did remember the last time you were vague posting.
That's true. >> Was that worth it? >> I think it
was. >> You think Ethan embedded a poison pill in the statement
that left her to open or left her open to litigation in the future?
No, cuz not by him. Like
h what would she have admitted to that she was like making some
of her statements totally disingenuously?
that she like made those statements only to cause harm to people,
dude. At that point, if that were the case, yikes.
Like, it would be insanely over, right? Please have faith. >> Simple
attack on two people who deeply care about Palestine and Palestinian
>> What the are you talking about?
>> I apologize for calling them cowards for not quitting
their jobs. That was a shameful attack on two people who deeply
care about Palestine and Palestinian people. AB along with his
wife Lena have done more than I have ever done for the Palestinian
people. [laughter] >> Never mind. A lawyer didn't write
this. Ethan did.
Wow. What's their chat saying?
It's probably emote only mode, right?
Nay nay no nay no. They're crying. Oh >> Including raising
over $100,000 in charity. That's a big amount. >> I didn't
fall asleep. I'm just Listen, this is like the fourth time we've
watched it through. So, I'm I'm like kind of So, I'm at the point
where I'm like probably good on this stuff. I'm not like I don't
know. I'm just probably good. Let's see. Let's see. Willy Willy
tweets. Hold on. I was right. Hassan never helped Caseyron was
lying by hinting that he would. He wanted praise from the public,
but didn't want to risk a dime. Classic Hassan. Ethan is getting
all the GoFundMe money.
Honestly, what a piece of [__] Wait, wait, what?
didn't want to risk a dime. Okay.
I mean, he sort of vague posted it once. I don't know. But it's
just kind of funny that Hassan is both a monster for not donating
and
for not donating. Donating and My brain just shut off. Hassan
is
both a monster if he donated and if he didn't donate. Okay. If
he donated, if he donated, he'd be totally hoodwinkedked by Ethan
Klein. He'd be totally lost. He would have lost. Okay? Because
all the money went to Ethan. But also, he's a total monster for
not donating. What a loser. What a loser, guys. If you do, if
you don't, God.
Anyway, what's up, Marmalade 166? How's it going, buddy?
There's a stream where when I'm awake. Well, not for much longer
because the stream is getting close to the end here.
God, I am like actually a little tired now. What's How long have
we been going for? Six and a half hours. I'll do like maybe a
little bit more. I think I said I'd do the Cash Patel thing.
Hold on. While I'm here, Destiny. GG. Uh, awesome.
I mean, true. But yeah, true. It's like one of those things where
it's like, "Oh, these people suck." And everybody here knows
it, so we don't really have to talk about it.
If anybody from DG ever wants to come in and argue, though, they're
welcome to come on stream. Okay, where are we going next? I think
we're going to do the FBI thing real quick. That Cash Patel FBI
thing. Kriski wanted to see that. Oh. Oh,
this is funny.
I I just noticed Kathy just posted this tweet in in a Discord.
So Hassan didn't want to didn't give a dime to Ethan. Sounds
like he won. Damn. Let's see
What the rude disavow? Uh I love when I love when they abuse
the socialism is when meme format that Hassan's community started
to mock them because he's just doing it. Like what does the principle
of socialism have to do with a frivolous lawsuit in any capacity?
Social socialism is when Hassan does nothing as Ethan sues Casey
Trron into oblivion. And we've got 49 [__] clapping
>> Oh yeah. Do it again, man. Hassan is bad. Hassan is
bad.
Is very bad.
I'm I'm like actually starting to get tired and I'm just trying
to get through it. Okay. I'm I'm entertaining myself a little
bit. Give me a second. We wanted to go over the real quick the
FBI letter. This whole thing.
Give me a second. How much is it?